اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه مفصله نناقش في معظمها
الازمه في السودان بدايتها كالعاده
بالعناوين
رغم الهدنه تجدد الاشتباكات في عده مناطق
في الخرطوم وسلاح الجو ينفذ طلعات جويه في
ام درمان
وزير ماليه السودان يدعو لفتح ممرات امنه
للكوادر الطبيه ومفوضيه اللاجئين تحذر من
اعاده الفرنه الى السودان
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
رئيس باجناري يهاجم روسيا ويتعاعد
بالانسحاب من معركه باغموت قريبا الكرملين
احتفظ بحق الرد
المرصد السوري يعلن مقتل ثلاثه بينهم
قيادي في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه بهجوم
تركي بريف الحسكه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله تشهد العاصمه السودانيه
مواجهات متقطعه منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
حيث تجددت قبل قليل الاشتباكات في محيط
منطقه المطار في العاصمه وشهدت اعمده
الدخان تتصاعد في سماء الخرطوم جراء
الاشتباكات المواجهات وقعت رغم اعلان
الطرفين الموافقه على هدنه جديده 72 ساعه
وبدت بان سلاح الجو السوداني نفذ طلعات
جويه في محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون وجنوب
مدينه ام درمان
وعلى وقع المواجهات اعلنت شبكه الاتصالات
ام تي ان توقف خدماتها في الخرطوم عن
العمل وذلك بسبب توقفه مقسمات الشركه في
الخرطوم عن العمل ما ادى لانقطاع جميع
الخدمات عن المشتركين جراء انقطاع الامداد
الكهربائي وقالت الشركه انها تعمل على
استعاده خدماتها وايجاد حلول باقرب وقت
قبل ذلك اكد دعم سريع في بيان قبوله تمديد
الهدنه وسبعين ساعه بوساطه سعوديه امريكيه
والالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار كما اعلن
الدعم السريع ترحيبه بالمبادرات المحليه
والاقليميه والدوليه لوقف اطلاق النار
بهدف فتح ممرات انسانيه وتسهيل حركه
المواطنين
[تصفيق]
ونعيد التذكير مشاهدينا بجمله الاخبار
العاجله قبل قليل اليونسف كانت تتحدث عن
نهب اكثر من مليون لقاح لشلل الاطفال في
السودان مراسل العربيه تحدث عن سماع اصوات
المضادات الارضيه بكثافه بمناطق عده شرقي
الخرطوم وبان الاشتباكات عادت لتتجدد من
جديد بعد ان بدات صباح اليوم توقفت ساده
الهدوء العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بعد ذلك
عادت الاشتباكات وعاده اعمده الدخان
للتصاعد من جديد في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم على كل حال الى شرق السودان ومن
بورتسودان يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي مرحبا بك معي نزار بدايه
السؤال عن عمليات الاجلاء من بورت سودان
كان من المتوقع وصول عدد من السفن من
المتوقع ايضا ان تبحر السفينه كذلك
البريطانيه التي كانت قد وصلت اول
الاسبانيه التي وصلت الى بورسودان كيف هي
الاوضاع من حولك
لك التحيه نحن الان نواكب هذه التغطيه
المستمره لاكثر من اسبوعين هنا في شرق
السودان تحديدا من مدينه بورسودان الذي
التي اصبحت فيها المسارات تتواصل مسارات
الانتقال من السودان الى عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه والعربيه والخليجيه
قبل قليل وصل نحو 153 من رعايه الدول
الاوروبيه الى هذه الباخره التي وصلت مساء
الامس وهي بارجه بحريه حربيه اسبانيه
باسم رينا صوفيا وصلت مساء الامس الى
ميناء بورسودان سيغادر بعد قليل على متنها
نحو 200 من حمله الجنسيات الاوروبيه لعدد
من الدول الاوروبيه هذه البارجه المزوده
بهليكوبتر وبقوات بحريه خاصه وصلت مساء
الامثله ميناء بورسودان
بعد وصول اشعارات وطلبات ايضا وصلت الى
اللجان المعنيه هنا في شرق السودان في
مدينه بورسودان لاستكمال اجراءات اجلاء
عدد من رعايه دول العربيه والاجنبيه
والافريقيه
في مطار بورسودان الصوره مماثله لما هو
الان في ميناء
بورسودان جسر جوي يوم الامس بدا من قبل
دوله الكويت سيستمر حتى يوم الاثنين
المقبل يحمل نحو 75 طنا من المساعدات
الغذائيه والاغاثيه والدوائيه ايضا قطر
بدات جسرا جويا على ذات المضمار وعلى ذات
الاطار نتحدث عن اكثر من 90 رحله جويه
وصلت الى مطار بورسودان واقلعت من هذا
المطار الذي يعتبر الان النافذه الجويه
الوحيده للسودان وللعالم نحو السودان هنا
في الشرق لايصال المساعدات لاخراج من يطلب
اللجوء ومن يطلب الاجلاء من سودا واكد بان
العمليات مستمره عمليات الخروج عمليات
الاجلاء بتنسيق واشراف مع عدد من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه مع الجيش مع الشرطه مع هيئه
الموانئ البحريه ممتاز
ماذا ايضا عن جدول كذلك السفن التي
[موسيقى]
تقدم الى بورتسودان سواء خلال ساعات
القريبه القادمه او ايضا حتى خلال هذه
الايام القليله بما ان هناك يعني جدول
واذونات تؤخذ حتى
تمخر هذه السفن باتجاه بورسودان
نعم يعني هذا الامر امر متواصل وامر متصل
اتصل المعلومات بصوره مستمره الى اللجنه
المعنيه هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر
الاستقبال طلبات قدوم السفن والبوارج
البحريه والقطع الحربيه الى ميناء
بورسودان هذه المعلومات دائما ما تاتي في
وقت متاخر بعد ان يتم الموافقه على دخول
السفن والقطع البحريه يتم الاعلام بان
سفينه قادمه من المنطقه المحدده ستصل خلال
الساعه المحدده الى ميناء بورسودان لكن ما
هو مؤكد ما هو مؤمل عليه بان مسار السفن
هو في استمرار بما ان مدينه بورسودان الان
تضم مئات من طالبي المغادره والطالبي
الاجلاء من السودان الى جده الى عدد من
الدول الاوروبيه والعربيه حتما فان السفن
والقطع البحريه ستصل الى مدينه بورسودان
خلال الساعات المقبله الشيء ايضا الذي
نؤكد عليه بان هذا الميناء منذ ان بدات
عمليه الاجلاء منذ الثاني والعشرين من شهر
ابريل الماضي يستقبل ما بين ثلاث الى ست
رحلات يوميا ودائما تمضي ما بين الرحلتين
الى ست الى خمس رحلات في اليوم هذا يؤكد
ايضا على ان مسار الرحلات مستمر على ان
الطلبات تاتي تباعا الى اللينه المعنيه
بالاجلاء في المطار وفي الميناء هذا يشير
الى ان الرحلات ستستمر خلال هذا الاسبوع
نزار اخيرا يعني كان هناك من معلومه
لعدد من تم اجلائهم منذ بدايه هذه الازمه
عدد من تم اجلائهم من ميناء بورسودان ان
كان هناك من رقم محدد او معلوم ومعروف
كذلك
نعم نتوقع التقرير النهائي ولكن المعلومات
التي بحوزاتنا الان وما هو متاح لنا من
مصادرنا
اكثر من 14 الف تم اجلائهم عبر هذا
الميناء الذي تتابعونه الان وعبر هذه
الصور الحصريه لقناه العربيه من الميناء
الاخضر هذا المرسى خرجت منه نحو 30 رحله
بحريه تضم نحو 13 الى 14 الف من طالبي
الاجلاء خلال الساعات الماضيه وخلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين مطار بورسودان على ذات
المنوال وعلى ذات النسق نحو 13 الى 14
ايضا تم اجلائهم وغادروا عبر المطار او
النافذ الرئيس الان للسودان وللعالم التي
تريد ان تدخل الى السودان عبر مطار
بورسودان وهذه الرحلات في استمرار مطار
بورسودان يستقبل يوميا ما بين ست الى سبع
رحلات هذه الرحلات تصل الى مطار بورسودان
باستمرار تنسق مع الطيران هنا في مدينه
بورسودان وينسقون مع الجيش وينسقون مع
ليله الامن وبعدها مباشره تحط الطائرات هي
طائرات حربيه
بدات قبل اسبوعين الان نتابع ونشاهد
طائرات لمساعدات من دول عربيه الحديثه عن
قطر الحديث عن الكويت وربما تمضي هذه
الرحلات
لنرى ونشاهد طائرات للاغاثه طائرات من
الامم المتحده الصليب الاحمر كل هذا الان
منفتح بما ان الامين العام او وكيل الامين
العام للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
اشار قبل يومين الى ان مدينه بورسودان
اصبحت نافذه لتقديم المساعدات فهذا يؤكد
ويعني بان شرق السودان وتحديدا الميناء
والمطار سيصبحان الارضيه والمنفذ الوحيد
لاستقبال المساعدات
ولاجلاما يريد مغادره السودان اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
التي وفيتنا بها من ميناء بورتسودا مراسل
العربيه نزار بكتاوي شكرا لك نزار
وهذه الصور المباشره مشاهدينا من العاصمه
السودانيه
الخرطوم التي تشهد كما نشاهد على شاشه
العربيه تصاعدا لاعمده الدخان
وتجدد المواجهات كما ذكرنا منذ ساعات
الصباح في عده مناطق بالعاصمه الخرطوم
بينها طبعا محيط منطقه المطار في
العاصمه الخرطوم كما ذكرنا والتي شهد
التجدد لاشبكات رغما الهدنه التي وافقت
عليها قوات الدعم السريع لمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه
ومعي هنا في الاستديو الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني محمود السيد محمود مرحبا بك معي
في هذه الساعه السودان ربما يعني هذه
الازمه هي اسبوعها ثالث لم يتم الالتزام
باي هدى بين الطرفين تم اختراقها جميع
الهدن اخترقت هل هناك من ضمانات لهذه
الهدنه لكي لا يتم اختراقها اما ان هذا
اصبح روتينيا اليوم في المشهد السوداني
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اشكرك على
الاستضافه في الحديث يعني المشهد السوداني
كل يوم يعني زايد في تعقد
والمتضرر هو المواطنين والسكان يعني حسب
المعلومات اللي عندي يمكن في 11 حي في
الخرطوم اخلي التمامه من السكان وهذا
يتضرر طبعا
الهدنه يعني حسب التجارب السابقه يمكن
جلودنا السابعه
واعتقد انه الطرفان المقتتلان هم اللذان
يستفيدان من هذه الهدنه وليس
السكان الاصليين الذين الان انقطعت عنهم
باي طريقه يستفيد طرف
وتعزيز مواقعهم يعني الان احنا كما نعلم
بعض الانباء التي تنقلها وكاله الانباء
انه قوات الدعم السريع بتحاول بقدر
الامكان انه تستقلب بقوات من خارج السودان
ومناطق موقعها بالذات في غرب السودان في
دارفور وعلى المناطق الحدوديه ما بين تشاد
وليبيا وهم يحاولون ان اعتقد انه الاخيره
لا اريد ان اقول انه اخسر المعارك ولكن
تضرر نوعا ما بعد اخراجه من كل قواعده
الموجوده في الخرطوم
وتشتت قواته في الشوارع يعني الا في بعض
المواقع كما هم يتحدثون امام القصر
الجمهوري او امام القياده العامه فبالتالي
انا اعتقد انه انا اعتقد انه الاعلان عن
اي هدنه قادمه ليس زاجته يعني كما ترى انت
الان العربيه تنقل كل الاخر يتهم الاخر
بانه هو يعني خرق هذه الهدنه وكما ذكرت لك
يعني الهدنه اليها قواعد لها نظم بحسب
قوانين جنيف انه لازم يكون هنالك طرف
محايد لمراقبه خطوط هذه الهدنه وتحديد
مواقعها وتحركات الطرفان يعني انا اعتقد
حدنا عشوائيه بهذه الطريقه لن تنجح ابدا
ولن تؤتي ثمارها ولن اكلها بالعكس سوف تظل
بهذه الوضع وفي ظ ل انه الطرفان لا
يلتزمان بها
ويستغلانها عسكريه
الاستغلال العسكري سيد محمود اليوم على
على الارض سواء بالطيران طيران الجيش
السوداني او حتى ايضا بالمضادات
الطيران التي يستخدمها قوات الدعم السريع
هل يمكن ان تاخذ الصراع لمساحه الجغرافيه
ابعد من العاصمه الخرطوم
الغريبه طبعا انا ممكن اربط الكلام ده مع
حدث في الابيض اليوم او امس مهاجمه القوات
المهاجمه القوات الجيش بالرغم انه في
الفتره الماضيه شاهدني انه القوات المسلحه
اعلنت بانه منطقه الابيض منطقه هادئه وتم
استعاده المطر يعني انا اعتقد انه اللي
انا استنتجت بانه الجيش قال انه كان في
قوات قادمه من نفس المنطقه ولكن تم
ملاحقتها بالطيران اعتقد هذه القوات رجعت
الى الاوبيض وهاجمت اللي هو قوات المسلحه
هنالك
يعني اذا هنالك ضيق الخناق على قوات الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم ان تنتقل المعرفه الى
غرب السودان بالذات المنطقه منطقه الجنينه
والفاشر هي يعني
معاقل قديمه للدعم السريع وستيل موجود
هنالك بعض القوات وممكن اذا في حاله خروج
بعض القوات من الخرطوم انه يعني يتحسن
الدعم السريع هناك وتستمر المعركه لفتره
طويله اليوم ميدانيا عسكريا على الارض هل
العاصمه الخرطوم اصبحت بمفاصيلها تحدث
الرئيسيه مؤسسات الدوله الحيويه ايضا كذلك
هل باتت تحت السيطره فعلا كما يقول الجيش
السوداني بان الاوضاع فيها مستقره وبانها
تحت السيطره ام لا زال الكر والفرع هو سيد
الموقف انت يا اخي الكريم لو لاحظت انه
نحن هناك في تكرار بالنسبه للمواقع التي
تذكرها وكالات الانباء يعني اصبحت هي
ثابته لنا القياده العامه القياده العطار
بحري
الصالحه وكذا انا اعتقد هؤلاء تبادل
الادوار يعني ما اعتقد في قوه واحده
استطاعت ان تثبت في موقع معين وتحتله
تماما انا اعتقد لكن على الاقل المطار
القياده العامه القصر الجمهوري يعني هذه
ربما الاهم اليوم في العاصمه الخرطوم هل
زمام الامور هناك بيد الجيش يعني انا بحسب
البيانات الموجوده الطرفين كل اخر يدعي
بانه يعني سيطر على القصر الجمهوري وما
ننتظر ساعه او ساعتين الا يعني بيان اخر
من الطفر انه هو في قسم وكمام بصور حيه من
المواقع المذكوره انا اعتقد في تحركات
بسيطه في منطقه المطار من الجيش السوداني
يعني لاول مره اشاهد يعني تحركات عسكريه
في الجيش في منطقه المطار التي كانت محتله
من قبل قوات الدعم السريع يمكن امس كانت
في الدباب طوال في الناحيه انما هو بين
شارع بيت خاتم ويعني الناحيه الشرقيه من
المطار انا اعتقد هذه مناوشات ولكن اعتقد
اللي يفهموا الجيش السوداني يبدو انه هو
بيسير في خطط ثابت وحكم الجيش نظامي يعني
لا يتحرك مثل الدعم السريع بقوات بدون ان
من جوانب مختلفه من من من اقسام مختلفه من
من الجهه السوداني اشكرك جزيل الشكر ضيفي
هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب الصحيحه في
السوداني محمود العوته شكرا سيدي شكرا
جزيلا
وزير الماليه السودانيه جبريل ابراهيم في
بيان له حول جهود مجلس الوزراء ازاء الوضع
الحالي في السودان قال ان مجلس الوزراء
يبذل كل الجهود مع اطراف الصراع لتوفير
المواد التموينيه والوقود في البلاد مشيرا
الى تشكيل لجنتين من قبل المجلس موضحا ان
اللجنه الاولى خاصه بالطوارئ الانسانيه
والثانيه مختصه بمتابعه ثياب السلع
والخدمات اللازمه وشدد ابراهيم في البيان
على اهميه فتح ممرات امنه لوصول الكوادر
الطبيه وغيرهم من الموظفين مباشره
لاعمالهم
طلبت مفوضيه الامم المتحده اللاجئين او
للاجئين الدول المستقبله للاجئين
السودانيين بعدم اعادتهم الى بلادهم بسبب
الصراع كما فادت بيانات المفوضيه الساميه
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين بان اخر
الاحصاءات الوارده من وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه تظهر تدفق اكثر من 56 الف شخص الى
البلاد
فرار من صراع السودان حتى الرابعه مما
يؤجري ووفقى مكتب المفوضيه فان من بين
هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين دخلوا الى بلاد من
معبري ارجين وقسط الملا يقل عن
52,500 سوداني ونحو 4000 من جنسيات اخرى
من جانبها حذرت منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيسف من ان المعارك الدائره في
السودان منذ ثلاثه اسابيع تحصد ارواح
اطفال باعداد كبيره مرعبه مشيره ايضا الى
ان التقارير تفيد بسقوط سبعه اطفال كل
ساعه بين قتيل وجريح
ايضا الدكتور هيثم محمد ابراهيم وزير
الصحه الاتحادي المكلف دكتور هيثم مرحبا
بك معنا على شاشه العربيه 20 يوما منذ بدا
هذا الصراع وهذه الازمه في السودان الى
اين وصل معها الوضع الانساني والصحي حسب
تقييمكم
شكرا جزيلا
طلال الحصه بتاعت الجمله الاخيره
والتقارير الينا من كل الولايات السودان
معظم الولايات التي كان لها سباق سابق
وبلغت 12 لكن حاليا عندنا فقط الخرطوم
وبعض النزاعات في ولايه غريبه
حركه الامداد
وبعض المستشفيات العامله بصوره كليه حسب
تقاريرا مركزيه حتى الان عدد الوفيات
الوارد الى المستشفيات او عبر المختلفه
حوالي 551
قديم في هذه الدول وصلت هذه المستشفيات
وهذه المشاريع وقرابه الخمسه الفحاله
اصابه تم التعامل معها في الولايات
السودان طيب
المستشفيات ايضا ما هي الاوضاع فيما يخص
العاصمه
الخرطوم خرطوم بحري ام درمان هذه المناطق
التي يدور حولها الاشتباك دكتور
بالنسبه للمستشفيات ولايه الخرطوم فيها
حوالي يعني 130 مستشفى بين مستشفى عام
ومستشفى خاص
المستشفيات المركزيه في مواقع الاشتباك
وبعض المواقع في بحر
توقفت عن الخدمه تشكل تقريبا حواليكم 30
مستشفى اي تقريبا بنت عددا المستشفيات
تنتمي الى المستشفيات في حالتي حاليا
قابله للخدمه بعض المستشفيات المركزيه
للاسف بها قوات الدعم السريعه ارتكاز
توصيف الخرطوم مستشفى خاصه المركزيه
مستشفى النساء والتوليد في ام درمان
هذه المستشفيات حاليا خارج الخدمه لهذا
السبب لكن بقيه المستشفيات
حوالي مستشفى في اطراف الطرطوم وكذلك
يستفيد من الولايات القريبه كيولات
الجزيره
في تحويل بعض الحالات للمعالجه في هذه
الولايات
هل هذه المستشفيات لديها القدره الطبيه
والكوادر ايضا الكافيه
يعني
سد حاجه المناطق المحيطه بها او للتعامل
مع الحالات التي تصلها دكتور
بالنسبه للكوادر هو العدد بتاع القواعد
الصالحيه او الطبيه في السودان كبير
الولايات تم حوالي الخرطوم مستقره ولايه
الجزيره وولايه نهر النيل حتى تم تحريك
بعض الطبيه من ولايه الخرطومات القريبه من
ولاد الجزيره قريبه من الكرتون بالتنسيق
مع عدد من الجمعيات الطبيه والمتطوعين في
ولايه الخرطوم الاشكاليه هي امكانيه وصول
الكوادر لهذه المستشفيات خاصه بيحتاج
احيانا يعضروا بعض المناطق اللي بيكون
فيها نزاع مسلح لكن
الكوادر تشتغل هذا القرمله يعني الكوادر
الساكنه في درمان مثلا يتم استغفاره للعمل
مثلا في بحر يتم استفاضه
لذلك
بمبادرات مع عدد من الجهات تم تشغيل
المراكز الصحيه حتى تتمكن من
الصيام ببعض القنوات الاساسيه دكتور
اليونيسف قبل قليل ذكرت بان هناك نهب
لاكثر من مليون لقاح للشراء للاطفال في
السودان اولا اتحدث عن دقه هذه المعلومات
وعن حاجه الاطفال اليوم في السودان
لهذه اللقاحات مثل هذه الظروف
بالتاكيد اللقاحات للاطفال دمتم الخمسه
المهمه في مكافحه الامراض الطفوله
برنامج التفصيل في السودان في ال 18 ولايه
تاثر بصوره اساسيه في ولايه دارفور وولايه
جنوب دارفور
سلسله التدريب
على
بقيه الولايات
المركزيه في الخرطوم السودان ما اصاب شيء
واجهات اشكاليه بتاعه الكهرباء والوقود
وتمت معالجتك في الايام الماضيه بقيه
الولايات ما فيها اشكاليه في تسيير
الخدمات الروتينيه للتطعيم سواء كان شبه
الاطفال او غيره بالتاكيد في تعاون وسند
كبير جدا للمنظمه الصحه العالميه ومنظمه
الانشاء في هذا الباب وهم معانا في
المركبيه والعواصف دائم في سد الفيديو
حاليا طيب هل هل وصلت الى السودان اي
مساعدات من هذه سواء من الصحه العالميه
ومنظمات الاغاثه الدوليه ايضا وغيرها
اتحدث عن المساعدات
الدوائيه التي وصلت الى السودان او الى
ايضا حتى العاصمه الخرطوم تحديدا
وصلت بالتنسيق مع عدد من المنظمات الدوليه
وبرضو الاصدقاء
ومن الدول العربيه الشقيقه
تم تحديد اولا الاحتياجات الاساسيه في
قواعد محدده من الغرفه الامداد المركزيه
الصحه الاتحاديه
متضمنه الحوجه في جانب
المستهلكات الجراحيه الادويه الاساسيه
لامراض المزمنه
الامراض الكلى وبعض المدخلات للصحه العامه
وصحه البيئه تمت استجابه واسعه جدا الكثير
من الشركاء بعض المنظمات لديها امداد
موجود داخل السودان تم تحريكه كمنظمه
الصحه العالميه ومنظمه اليونيسيف وتمت
الاستفاده منه في بعض المستشفيات كذلك بعض
المنظمات الاخرى اطب
مختلفه برضو مشاركات وتشغيل بالاضافه لذلك
تم تحريك الامداد داخل السودان بين
الولايات المختلفه للعلم
المركزيه انها 18 سنه مختلفه بهذه الفروع
يوجد بعض المخزون الدوائر تم تحريكه بين
الولايات المختلفه
مع تم اللقاء مع وزراء الصحه العرب في
اجتماع منظمات الجامعه العربيه
دول العربيه حتى حاليا
ونشهد بدايه وصول حزب من الامدادات الطبيه
وفق الحوجه من عدد من الدول العربيه على
الاشقاء من الكويت من قطر من سلطنه عمان
بدانا نستلم بعض المعينات الاساسيه عبر
منفذ البحر الاحمر
بورتسودان تحديدا الدكتور يعني انت ذكرت
قبل قليل ان هناك اصحاب امراض مزمنه وربما
ايضا حتى من تطول مده بقائهم في
المستشفيات من المصابين بالسرطان او
بامراض الكلى وغيرها هذه المستشفيات التي
كانوا يعني مقيمين فيها كيف تاثرت بانقطاع
التيار الكهربائي المستمر في العاصمه
الخرطوم
كونا اللي جاي من كل التخصصات لجنه خاصه
بامراض الكلى على سبيل المثال لجنه خاصه
بامراض السرطان وتم تحميل
للعلاج في مستشفيات اخرى بالتاكيد هو
مستشفى واحد لكل الاورام ولا مستشفى واحد
على سبيل المثال مراكز السودانيه واربع
مركز
اكثر من 80 مركز حاليا شغاله في اداره
بتبدا المشقه على المرضى هي تحريكم من
مراكز لاخرى بعيده من المناطق احيانا
النكته الثانيه بالنسبه
للادويه خاصه لامراض الكلى وامراض السرطان
اصلا سياسه السودان قبل هذه الحرب هذه
الكامله من المواطنين تتلقى هذه العلاجات
مجانا من برنامج يسمى بالعلاج المجاني
المخزون الموجود في هذه الامراض في مكان
حوالي
55% قبل الحرب في بعض الاصناف كانت مطلوبه
مثلا على سبيل المثال الغسل الكلى
ومشكورين الشركه معها التنسيق جامعه
البحر الاحمر
الولايات المختلفه
كانت اشكاليه لانه كان الموجود بسيط لا
يفيد سبب التعاون والتنسيق مع بعض الجهات
شركه الحكمه الاردنيه تبرعت بمجموعه من
العاديه دكتور دكتور اخيرا
دكتور اخيرا كيف
تستطيعون او من يؤمن ايضا حتى حمايه هذه
المستشفيات من ان لا تتحول الى تكنات
عسكريه كما تحولت بعض المستشفيات
دي واحده من اصعب الملفات المتواليه حديثا
ومعقده جدا نحن في الصحه وعبر اللجان
العليا لتنسيق عمل الخدمات الطبيه
والانسانيه عملنا مناشده ومناداه بعدم
اتخاذ المستشفيات
الصحيه سكنات عسكريه ووجهنا رساله واضحه
للم
دام الكريم وعدم اتخاذ هذه المستشفيات
كمقارها والسكنات وكذلك رساله
البريد هذه المقارنه تكون مواقع الاشتباط
نامل الاستجابه من
الدعم التاريخي الابتعاد عن المستشفيات
خاصه بعض المستشفيات في مستشفى الجره
ومعمل المعمل القومي
قد يكون كل شيء من الخطوات اشكرك جزيل
الشكر الدكتور هيثم محمد ابراهيم وزير
الصحه الاتحادي المكلف شكرا جزيلا لك
الان منظمه الصحه العالميه تعلن انتهاء
العمل
بالحاله الطارئه لفيروس كورونا ننتقل
مباشره لكلمه او طبعا
نتابع هذه الاخبار العاجله اسفل الشاشه
نقلا عن الصحه العالميه التي اعلنت رسميا
انتهاء حاله الطوارئ العالميه المرتبطه
بفيروس كورونا الصحه العالميه ايضا قالت
بان فيروس كورونا قد تسبب بوفاه 20 مليون
شخص على الاقل يذكر طبعا بان هذا الفيروس
بدا بالانتشار في اواخر 2019 بالصين وبعد
ذلك انتشر في
انحاء العالم
نعد الى الملف السوداني حيث دعا المستشار
الالماني خلال زيارته لكينيا الى انهاء
الصراع في السودان مؤكدا على ان الشعب
السوداني دافع عن الديمقراطيه لسنوات
لقد دافع الكثير من الناس في السودان عن
الحريه والديمقراطيه لسنوات وغالبا ما
يخاطرنا بحياتهم كما دافعوا عن عمليه
الانتقال من الحكم العسكري الى المدني يجب
على الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع انهاء
صراعيهما على السلطه الذي يحدث على حساب
السودانيين ونحن في غايه الامتنان لجهود
دوله كينيا
ساهم الجيش السوداني وعلى مر سنوات طويله
في الحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار الداخلي
وحتى الحدودي ضمن استراتيجيه عسكريه محكمه
تمكن من خلالها من مواجهه كافه التحديات
والتهديدات الحدوديه المحتمله تفاصيل اكثر
نتابعها مع فارس الصلوات
حيوي مهم لعبه الجيش السوداني منذ استقلال
البلاد في عام
1956 حيث كان الحفاظ على الاستقرار وتهدئه
الاضطرابات الداخليه ومواجهه التحديات
الحدوديه اولويه قصوى مناطق عسكريه ووحدات
قتاليه بريه ونقاط تفتيش عسكريه تابعه
للجيش السوداني موجوده على طول الحدود
التي تربطه بدول الجوار شمالا هنا حيث
الجار مصر توجد مناطق عسكريه تابعه للجيش
السوداني تحديدا جنوب مثلث حلايب في ولايه
البحر الاحمر كما توجد كاتبه الفرقه
التاسع عشر بمدينه مروي والتي تطل على
طريق شريان الشمال الرابط بين مصر
والسودان على الضفه المقابله مثلث اخر على
الحدود الليبيه السودانيه هناك ايضا قاعده
مركزيه كبيره للجيش السوداني اما غربا
وبحدود بريه تزيد عن 2000 كيلو متر مع
السودان تنتشر فيها قوه مشتركه بهدف تامين
تلك الحدود فقط وفي افريقيا الوسطى التي
تمزقها الحرب يوجد الجيش السوداني ضمن
نقاط تفتيش عسكريه عند الدخول والخروج اما
على الحدود السودانيه
يمكن والتي يمكن ان تتحول لقاعده لتدفق
السلاح ينتشر الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط
تفتيش كبرى في كسلا والحدود المتاخمه مع
اريتريا ضمن حاميه عسكريه نقطه صراع هنا
وعلى تلك الحدود المشتعله حينا وحين مع
اثيوبيا ينتشر الجيش السوداني في منطقه
الفشقه التي تقع في ولايه الجضارف وايضا
في منطقه الجلابات وولايه النيل الازرق
وفي جنوب البلاد هناك العديد من
المناطق العسكريه ينتشر فيها الجيش
السوداني شمال ابيي شمال ابيي كما نتابع
وكذلك في كوردوفان وولايه النيل الابيض
حدود بريه واسعه يتشاركها السودان مع دول
عديده فرضت على الجيش اتباع استراتيجيه
تحكمها ضوابط عسكريه لحمايه وتعزيز وجوده
على طول الشريط الحدودي
توقعات طوالي
والان الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
وملفات اخرى
[موسيقى]
اذا على وقع تصاعد المعارك في باخمه شرق
اوكرانيا حذر ايفيجيني رئيس مجموعه
ايفاجنر من ان قوته ستغادر مدينه باخموت
في العاشر من مايو الجاري بسبب عدم تامين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الذخيره لقوته وقال
بريجوجين ان استمرار القتالي في مدينه
باقمت من دون ذخيره امر لا جدوى منه
بالاضافه الى تكبد خسائر بين مقاتل فاجنر
خلال المواجهات في باخموت
بحلول التاسع من مايو قلنا على وشك
الاستيلاء على بخموت لكن بعد ان راوا هذا
التقدم اوقف البيروقراطيون شبه العسكريين
توريد الذخيره لمنعنا من القيام بذلك
يعتقدون انهم سوف يدخلون التاريخ ابلغت
وزير الدفاع ورئيس هيئه الاركان والقائد
الاعلى رسميا بان رفاقي لن يتكبدوا خسائر
غير مبرره في باخموت بدون ذخيره لذا في
العشر من مايو سننسحب من باغموت
من جانبه يتحفظ ناطق باسم الكرم للنادي
متريس عن الاجابه عن سؤال صحفي حول اخر
تصريح لرئيس
فاغنر ايفيغيني حول التراجعي من باغمه
طبعا شاهدنا ذلك في وسائل الاعلام لكن لا
يمكنني التعليق لان الامر يتعلق بالعمليه
العسكريه الخاصه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مباشره الى هناك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر رائد مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره
بدايه كيف يمكن تقييم الامور في الشرق
الاوكراني في بخمت تحديدا التي هدد رئيس
مجموعه باجنار بالانسحاب منها في التاسع
من مايو
نايف لمتابعه ما بداناه في النشرات
الصباحيه لابد من تسليط الضوء على الشرق
الاوكراني وخاصه مقاطعه الاكثر سخونه بكل
المحاور والمعارك الساخنه التي تجري في
هذه المقاطعه لكن نحن الان نتواجد في احد
الاسواق او المواقع التي تم قصفها قبل
ايام لان القصف متبادل ما بين الجيش
الاوكراني والقوات
الروسيه
والقصف يطال المدنيين سنتحدث عن المحاور
في ذات الوقت الذي الكاميرا تسلط فيه
الضوء على اثار القصف المتبادل هنا في
مدينه دانيسك بالفعل مدينه باقمت ما زالت
تشهد اسخن المعارك نايف رغم تهديد
بالانسحاب وتسليم النقاط التي سيطر عليها
او يعني القواعد التي وصلت اليها القوات
الروسيه وقوات فاجنر في اخر المدينه من
الناحيه الغربيه وما زالت القوات حتى هذه
اللحظه تحاول الدخول من الناحيه الشماليه
الغربيه الى بلده بغداد نفقه ومن الناحيه
الجنوبيه الغربيه بلده ايفانا من اجل قطع
الامدادات العسكريه عن القوات الاوكرانيه
من طريق تشاسوفار السريع الذي يوصل
الامدادات الى القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت
تتمركز القوات الاوكرانيه في الناحيه
الغربيه وما زالت تحافظ وتدافع عن المدينه
بقوه من تلك المناطق بالفعل هناك محاور
عديده في الشرق الاوكراني مثل
ومارينكا شهدت عوده للقوات الاوكرانيه بعد
امدادات عسكريه اضافيه حيث ان مدينه
مارينكا من الناحيه الغربيه تشهد معارك
كبيره نذكر بان الجيش الروسي سيطر على
ثلثي المدينه وتبقى الجزء الغربي وهو
الثلث الاخير هناك عوده في مدينه نحو بلده
محاوله من قبل الجيش الاوكراني للسيطره
على هذه البلده التي يتقدم فيها الجيش
الروسي لكن القوات الروسيه او المصادر
العسكريه من هناك ذكرت بانها صدت هذا
الهجوم كما ان الجيش الروسي المتمركز في
الثلثين ثلثي مدينه مارينكا المتاخم
لمدينه افديفكا نفذ عمليات هجوم على
الناحيه الغربيه من مدينه افديفكا ومعارك
ضاريه في هذا المحور تمكن جيش الروسي نايف
من توسيع الطوق طبعا هي الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه في دخول المدن والسيطره عليها
بدايه بالتطويق ومن ثم الدخول الى الاحياء
في اطراف المدن الوصول الى الوسط ومن ثم
دفع الجيش الاوكراني الى الانسحاب من اخر
المدينه تحاول القوات الروسيه تطويق مدينه
كما كان في مدينه باخم وتحاول الوصول الى
اكمال نصف الهلال حتى الان لم يكتمل نصف
الهلال لكنها وسعت الطوق خلال 48 ساعه
الماضيه
لتوسيع الحصار على القوات الاوكرانيه
وهناك عمليات عسكريه بالاليات الثقيله
تشهد كل ليله قصف عنيف حتى الصباح قصف
عنيف من قبل القوات الروسيه ضد القوات
الاوكرانيه المتمركزه والمحصنه جيدا داخل
مدينه افديفكا يبقى المحور الاهم وهو
تصريحات وسط صمت كما اسلفت بسكوب لم يعلق
على ما صرح به
وبكلمات بذيئه سلطت الضوء على نقص الذخيره
وتعمد الدفاع الروسيه بعدم امداد قواته
واضح الاسلحه لافشال عملياته والافشال
تقدمه وقال بان
الدفاع الروسيه تمنع النصر عن روسيا وليس
عن قوات
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من دونك
مراسل العربيه رائد الاكبر شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا وفي ذات الشان اكد وزير الخارجيه
الروسي ان الهجوم على كان عملا عدائيا
وروسيا سترد بخطوات ملموسه واعتبر الابروف
ان كيف لن تحاول مهاجمه الكريم دون دون
اخطار سادتها في الغرب حسب وصفك فكشف وزير
الخارجيه روسيا ايضا ان موسكو مستعده
للتحدث مع الغرب وهذا سيحدث عاجلا ام اجلا
من الواضح انه كان عملا عدائيا ومن الواضح
تماما ان ارهابي كيف لم يكن بامكانهم
ارتكاب هذه الحادثه دون علم القياده
الاوكرانيه لن نرد عما اذا كان ذلك سبب
الحرب ام لا لكننا حتما سنرد بالافعال
ونحن لدينا الكثير من الصبر وبالحديث عن
موقف واشنطن لقد اطلعت على بيان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتون بلينكن الذي قال
فيه ان الولايات المتحده لن تملي على
اوكرانيا ما ينبغي فعله اتجاه قيادتها
وهذا يوضح كل شيء
من جانبه حضر نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
من ان العلاقه الروسيه الامريكيه تقترب من
حافه مواجهه المسلحه مشيرا الى ان موسكو
تحاول الحفاظ على العلاقات مع واشنطن لمنع
سقوطها في هويه النزاع المسلح واضاف رياض
كوفا ان روسيا مستعده لاستخدام كل الوسائل
الممكنه لضمان عدم السماح لاي
بالتعدي على امن روسيا وسلامه رئيسها
وقيادتها السياسيه
رغم التحذيرات الروسيه اكد ناطق باسم
الكرم ان اتصالات روسيا مع الولايات
المتحده ستستمر للحفاظ على المصالح
اي اتصالات ممكنه للوصول الى اهدافنا
لتوفير مصالحنا بالطبع ستستمر الاتصالات
اذا لزم الامر
امريكا الدوله الكبرى
عضو المجد مجلس الامن للامه المتحده مثل
روسيا سنه شعبيه وبعد دول اوروبيه لذلك
حوار بين لابد منه هذا هو كان يعني ان في
نهايه المطاف سوف مضطرين ان نلتقي نحبنا
نحن او لا نحب
الظروف الدوليه لا شاكي يفرضوا على امريكا
وعلى روسيا
مخرج الوحيد لانه اي واحد في امريكا يحلم
عن هزيمه روسيه وعلى حقل القتال هذا احلام
معناتها ان لا يمكن ان يتكلموا مع روسيا
انا يعني ولايات المتحده الامريكيه
دي من موقف القوه العسكريه
عاجلا او اجلا هم سيكون مضطرين ان يجلسوا
ويناقشوا المواضيع
الاهميه مشتركه لكن هذا هذا الحديث
سيدوف يعني ينافي ما قاله السيد وزير
الخارجيه عندما قال بان العلاقه مع
الولايات المتحده في وقتنا الحالي تقترب
من ان تهوي الى الى
يعني سماها بهكذا اسمي لحافه المواجهه
المسلح
طبعا هناك حرب حرب بالوكاله اليوم امريكا
وكلت اوكرانيا لحوض المعركه
المصالحه مع روسيا فيدراليه واي واحد يمكن
يتوقع غدا وغدا هذا يعني خلال سنه القادمه
سنه القادمه سنه انتخابات الامريكي رئاسه
الامريكيه ولذلك اي فكره بيجي الى
ذهن الرئيس الامريكي بايدن وهو يعارض كل
الافكار بسياسه خارجيه تصور سياسه
الخارجيه امريكيه في
لدي دونالد ترامب منافسه الاساسي لا احد
يعرف لذلك
احتمال استدام المسلح ممكن ولكن الروشا
تبرز قدره العسكريه كافيه لكي يرده على كل
الاحتمالات
وحوسه مستعده لهذا
التوجه
فيما يخص الرد الملموس الذي تحدث عنه وزير
الخارجيه الروسي على يعني محاوله استهداف
بوتين هل برايك ستتخطى روسيا ما تبقى من
اي خطوط حمراء في حربها على اوكرانيا
لا روسيا تاخذ المواقف معقوله مدروسه ولا
شك ان الرد سيكون رضوان ليست هو عين على
العين وروسيا محاوله
توجيه الضرب على مركز اتحاد القرارات
الروسيه وهي كريملين والقصر نمره واحده
حيث كان مكتب الرسمي
واداره بوتين طبعا هذا دليل على انه هذا
اشاره من قبل الولايات المتحده عبر
امكانيات اوكرانيه او حتى اذا كانت هذا
الطياره مسيره يرسلها من ذواحي موسكو
وليست من اراضي اوكرانيا كان ضعيف ترتب كل
هذا
الهجومات اوكرانينيه على ينفو هذا او
استخبارات الامريكيه
استخبارات امريكيه اوكرانيه منتشره في
روسيا بشكل واضح تماما
يحتاج لاحتمام من قبل
مخابرات الروسيه بلاك يشتغل في المجال
شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو الدبلوماسي السابق
والمحلة الاساسي في
شكرا اعلنت تركيا نقله نحو 30 مليون طن من
المنتجات الزراعيه الاوكرانيه في اطار
تنفيذ مبادره البحر الاسود للحبوب وفقا
لبيانات الرسميه فان
933 سفينه نقلت المنتجات الزراعيه
الاوكرانيه بينها 50% من محصور الذره و28
من القمح اتاتي الصين واسبانيا وتركيا
وايطاليا وهولندا على قائمه الدول الخمس
الاولى التي تم تصدير الحبوب اليها
[موسيقى]
سلطات البلجيكيه لرجل عراقي تهمه جرائم
قتل بنيه ارهابيه والمشاركه في انشطه
ارهابيه وجرائم حرب واخرى ضد الانسانيه
واوضح مكتب المدعي العام الفيدرالي ان
المشتبه به يعيش في بلجيكا منذ عام 2015
يعتقد انه
يعتقد انه ينتمي لخليه تابعه للقاعده
اشتركت في تفجيرات داخل المنطقه الخضراء
وسط بغداد في عام 2009 و2010 قتلها خلالها
نحو 376 شخصا وجرح اكثر من 2300 شخص
اعلنت ايرانه ان اربعه دبلوماسيين
اذربيجانيين بينهم اثنان من سفاره
اذربيجان في طهران واثنين من القنصليه
العامه في تبريز عناصر غير مرغوب بها
للبقاء على الاراضي الايرانيه وياتي اعلان
طهران بعد الهجوم بعد الهجوم الذي وقع في
السفاره اذربيجانيه في العاصمه الايرانيه
واعلان باكو عن طرد اربعه موظفين بالسفاره
الايرانيه في باكو باعتبارهم عناصر غير
مرغوب بهم
بعد اختتام الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
زياره استمرت اليومين الى دمشق رحب بيان
المشترك لسوريا وايران بالتطورات السياسيه
الاخيره الايجابيه التي تشهدها المنطقه
خاصه فيما يتعلق
بتواصلي سوريا البناء مع الدول العربيه
وكذلك الاتفاق الايراني السعودي حيث اكد
البيان ان استئناف العلاقات بين الرياض
والطيران بواسطه صينيه في مارس الماضي
يشكل خطوه مهمه نحو مزيد من التطورات
الايجابيه التي تخدم استقرار الشرق الاوسط
وشدد البيان المشترك على ضروره التضامن
والتماسك بين دول المنطقه لمواجهه
التحديات وتوفير الامن والهدوء عبر
التعاون الاقليمي
اعلن المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان في بيان
عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص من بينهم قياديهم في
وحدات الدفاع الذاتي التابعه لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وذلك بهجوم من قبل طائره
مسيره تركيا بريف الحسكه وقال المرصد الى
المسيره التركيه استهدفت
سياره عسكريه تقل العناصر الثلاثه في قريه
قيروان بمنطقه تلحميس شمال شرق الحسكه
شاركت الجاليه التركيه في المانيا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه واقترع
الالاف لمرشحهم المفضل طوال الايام
الماضيه ويحق لمليون ونصف المليون تركيا
يعيشون في المانيا التصويت في الانتخابات
في السنوات الماضيه صوتوا بمعظمهم للرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
الرئاسيه التركيه وهنا امام القنصليه
التركيه في برلين صفوف طويله من الناخبين
يصطفون للادلاء بصوتهم اصوات الاتراك في
المانيا تذهب بمعظمها بحسب اتجاهات
التصويت في السنوات الماضيه للرئيس الحالي
رجب طيب اردوغان ومع ذلك هذه المره كانت
المعارضه حاضره هنا وان بصوره خجوله معظم
الاتراك في المانيا الذين قدموا بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كانوا مهاجرين عمال
ومكثوا هنا كثيرون منهم ما زالوا يشعرون
بارتباط قوي مع تركيا وكثيرون ايضا خاصه
الكبرى في السن لا يحملون الجنسيه
الالمانيه حتى
اردوغان لديه صوره القائد القوي الذي
يمكنه ان يواجه الغرب والاتراك الذين
يعيشون في المانيا يحبون هذه الصوره وكذلك
هم لا يتاذون من الوضع الاقتصادي في تركيا
الواصلون الجدد الى المانيا من المعارضين
السياسيين مثل حسين دمير واجوزان البيرق
الذين لجاوا بعد الانقلاب الفشل ياملون ان
تحمل الانتخابات في تركيا تغييرا قد ينعكس
عليهم
امل ان تفوز المعارضه فهم وعدوا بانهم
سيحترمون حقوق الانسان ويعيدون العمل
بالقانون وهذا يعني ان كل الاتهامات
الباطله سيتم رفعها وسيصبح القضاء مستقلا
اصوات الاتراك في الخارج تشكل قرابه
الثلاثه نصفهم يصوتون في المانيا ما يعني
ان اصوات الاتراك هنا قد تحدث فرقا في حال
كان الاقبال مرتفعا وهو ما يبدو الحال
عليه هذا العام راغده بهنام العربيه برلين
سجل حزب المحافظين البريطانيه الذي يحكم
البلاد منذ 13 عاما نتائج اوليه سيئه في
الانتخابات المحليه التي جرت في انجلترا
امس الخميس ومني المحافظون بخسائر كبيره
في المعاكل التقليديه لليمين البريطاني في
انتخابات تجديد المجالس البلديه
[تصفيق]
في لندن تستمر لاجراءات الامنيه واغلاق
بعض الطرق في المدينه استعدادا لحفل تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث
[موسيقى]
قد اظهرت مقاطع مصوره لحظه وصول الملك
تشارلز الثالث قبل قليل حيث تجمع حشد كبير
من المواطنين لالقاء التحيه عليه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بملفنا الاول السودان فقد امتدت تاثيرات
الحرب الدائره فيه على المغتربين
السودانيين في الرياض التي يجتمعوا بها
اكثرهم يواسي السودانيون بعضهم البعض في
الجلوس معا في المقاهي والجمعيات يحاولون
المساهمه بتخفيف المعاناه عن الشعب
السوداني باي وسيله كانت
[موسيقى]
لم يالفوا حوارات تدور حول قصف وقذائف
تضرب عاصمه بلادهم بخور القهوه الذي
يشاركهم الحديث يذكرهم بالدخان المتصاعد
من ابنيه الخرطوم هكذا انقلبت احوال
الجاليه السودانيه في الرياض من حديث عن
هموم الغربه الى قلق على الوطن
الاوضاع سيئه بالنسبه لنا لك ناس مغتربين
وبعديهمنا وكده فالواحد يعني حزين لكن
نسال الله ان ربنا يسهل الامور ويرفع
البلاء عن العباد والبلاد ان شاء الله
لحتى ما قدرنا نعيد على عيالنا فهمت علي
انه الواحد ما قدر يصل لعياله عن طريق
تليفون ولا عن طريق اي برامج من برامج
التواصل الاجتماعي في الاماكن العامه
والاماكن الخاصه يشترك سودانيون في هذه
الايام بالحديث عن الحرب ولا غير الحرب
حديث لم يعتادوا عليه طوال العقود الماضيه
لكنهم قلقون مما يحدث في الداخل لسيما وان
اهاليهم واصدقائهم لا زالوا في مدن تضربها
النيران
كلما طرفت عيني يرف ضياء
وذكريات احبائي اذا خطرت احس بالموت فوق
البحر يلعب بي مواساه قد تنطق بها ابيات
شعريه وتعبر عنها نظرات الحضور هنا مشهد
القريه حاضر في صلب الاحاديث اخرون
يتسمرون امام الشاشات بحثا عن نهايه لهذا
الكابوس
اعتادوا على التكافل الاجتماعي في
جمعياتهم وتقديم الدعم للمغتربين للجدد
لكنهم شرعوا هذه المره في محاوله تقديم
الدعم المادي لقريتهم في شمال السودان
لمساعده اهاليهم الذين نزحوا من الخرطوم
هربا من الحرب
الان في الخرطوم كل التجاره متوقفه يعني
في اي لحظه اذا استمر
الكلاج ده لمده شهر حتحصل مجاعه داخل
الخرطوم ناس بالذات المغتربين الموجودين
هنا الكاتبهم هناك ويعني قدروا يعملوا نوع
من النفير على اساس انه يساعده الاسره
العالقه ما قادره ما عندها امكانيه توصل
لاهلها في الشمال الناس يتعاون كل الجمعيه
في حدود اهلها علق الكثير من المغتربين
السودانيين المقيمين في السعوديه في بدايه
الحرب بالخرطوم بعضهم استطاع العوده من
خلال سفن الاجلاء السعودي
فيما يخطط الكثير ممن التقيناهم هنا لجلب
عائلاتهم الى السعوديه في حال استمرار
الحرب عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
الرياض
هذه الساعه مشاهدينا التي خصصنا معظمها
للحديث عن الملف السوداني وعن الاشتباكات
في السودان التي دخلت يومها العشرين انتهت
وفي جزء طبعا الثاني تناولها عدد من
الملفات الاخرى ايضا الزميله رشا نبيل
تلقاكم على راس الساعه وانا اترككم في
رعايه الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات